So I wanted to ask you if all the many,
many things of the hundreds and thousands
of things that you could do with your
time.
How did you get exposed to coding and,
and walk me through your first
experience or experiences with that.
Although I love the way that you,
you explain it as language
and that's really what it is.
And I think that like any language,
it's a medium that you
can express yourself,
that you can express creative ideas.
And that is what I,
why I think it's so powerful.
I got exposed to it because I'm
just a super curious, like annoying,
like her curious person.
I ask a lot of questions and I
love understanding how things work.
I love understanding like how
the world around me works and,
and how science and math can
be ways to explain that. I,
but I work in a really creative
industry and, and I, I dunno,
I guess I at a certain point
in a couple of years ago,
I wanted to understand what code was.
It was the term they kept hearing.
Did it I person a
conversation. Yeah. I mean,
I was meeting a lot of entrepreneurs,
I was watching the entire world,
especially fashion and media be
transformed by technology. And I was like,
what is it that a handful of people
who are engineers and building huge
enterprise value,
what is the sake secret language that
they know that the rest of us don't and
code. And I was like, what is code and
how can I learn it? So I took a boot camp,
I took one one week and even in where,
where was it in New York at the flat iron
school. Who introduced you to that? Um,
this guy,
Avi fluff bomb and he's a great teacher
and he started this school and he taught
me ruby similar exactly as yeah.
So like it's a very intuitive
kind of language. And,
and even in a short time I was able
to kind of understand high level big
principles and the fact
that you can use code to,
you know, write a line of code that
performs a function and you can build,
you can build ideas using this language.
And that to me was just so mind blowing
to understand like how the tech that we
touch every day, how it works
and to take it one step further,
but to actually be able to,
to write it yourself and to express
your ideas and to be able to, I mean,
you're a man, you're so efficient,
Tim. It's really inspiring.
You're so organized and so fishing
organized for maybe like two hours a day,
two hours and you are,
it's impressive.
And I just think that like even you can
build tech to enable that and to scale
that.
And that's what's so powerful is the
ability to scale ideas or scale problem
using code.
And,
and I think that there's so much
opportunity that has yet to really even be
built in this kind of
intersection of kind of, uh,
many intersections of,
of kind of creative industries with,
from the perspective of someone writing
code who has different life experiences
or passions may be then,
um,
then most engineers sitting in Silicon
Valley today and you take this class,
yeah.
You learn the basics of ruby with avi,
with Avi.
And how does the,
what is Kode with Klossy?
So Kode with Klossy
is my organization where we teach girls
to learn how to code and empower the
next generation of tech leaders.
So we do that by running summer
camps across the country.
And we teach girls the ABC's.
So Ruby html,
javascript, CSS, enough to
be able to build something.
So our camps are across the country and
there are two weeks long and they're
totally free.
And we have these amazing
girls who come into our,
our,
our camps and learn these skills.
And it's amazing what
they're able to build.
And not only just the way that
they're able to build their ideas,
but what they're passionate about. So
if it's like making social impact, uh,
helping their community, um, but they,
they're able to build something and
recognize the impact that they can have.
Um, and that's really
empowering and that's that,
that for a girl who's kind of,
you know,
at that point in life where you're like
figuring out what you think you can be
or what you think you can't,
like, that's really empowering.